I want to go right to Alex because she
was engaged for 11 years
sorry about that 11-year engagement so
you're with a guy for 11 years that
didn't turn into an engagement can you
clarify yeah so I was with him 11 years
engaged with him for six months and then
called that off so high school
sweetheart
who turned out not to be such a high
school 11 years together get engaged for
six months you said I'm not having it
I'm out that was it
there's more to the story
of cheating on me with my best friends
who's no longer my best friend you know
going back to um Sophie's Fitness
Nutrition you trying to bring somebody
else into your world who may actually
not really be ready or disciplined
enough and have the mindset of going in
uh okay I just have my eyes for this one
woman I'm gonna build with her rather
than you go into a CrossFit sort of
environment where you know women
throwing weights around and sports bras
and booty shorts and eyes tend to wander
mm-hmm so that's where it happened the
CrossFit Studio
yeah
and that was a nail in the coffin you're
not going to tolerate that
not being
English and then finding out through her
husband that was kind of the nail in the
coffin oh so she was married then she
was married with an eight-year-old son
so that's where you know in one of the
topics can men and women be friends
um and it'd be platonic and it's just
like to an extent
um you want to have the trust and faith
in in your significant other and then
with your best friend and
so did you did you at one time believe
that men and women could be friends but
you've changed your opinion on that
you have to have a very strong-minded
and disciplined man and there has to be
a purpose behind that friendship is what
I'm learning is that if you need a woman
or a man for emotional support is are
you really in touch with yourself
entirely if you need that kind of
support I feel like if you're in a
relationship the way that you look at
others should be more transactional
in my opinion now
if you're in a relationship the way that
you look at others should be transaction
okay I think that's a fair statement
um did you end up giving back the
engagement ring
no I did not ah why
um do you still have it on
no okay
I know I don't wear it that was two
years ago okay I think the ring that I
was wearing was like a University of
Denver ring okay yeah that doesn't look
like an engagement ring that I got yeah
well it is my fat finger didn't it
didn't fit on that fingers so but it is
a little bit like you know putting up a
ring on that finger that I personally
had made that has more significance is
why I still tend to wear so I always
find that to be an interesting question
is if you know if the engagement's
called off for whatever reason should
the engagement ring be returned
you obviously think that it shouldn't be
because because you kept it I think it
depends on the situations
and I know that that everybody has the
different viewpoints but if you cheated
on me I feel like that that ring
and you're right I I still have it I
haven't sold it but for some people you
know they want to
keep it as a Memento or
use it for future funds
do you think that if you got involved
with another guy later on down the road
and you found out that you had kept the
engagement ring and it's still something
in your possession you'd be you know
pleased about that
no
I don't
okay
um what about the other gals like uh
Ashley and Sophie what do you think of
the notion of an engagement ring if it's
called off do you keep the ring do you
return it like what's your position on
that and why
is this circumstantial like if he cheats
on you then you have to keep it like as
a punishment or
I don't know if I see it as a punishment
but I feel like
if I was me personally if I was in that
situation I would probably
sell it
um because you know I got cheated on
after 11 years
so I you know
but I feel like I have I might as well
gain something from it but if the other
person wants it back I feel like there's
no point in keeping it like I'm not you
know I don't have any strong opinions
towards it if the other person is like
really adamant that they need it back in
their possession for whatever reason
then I'll give it back if not what about
you Sophie what do you think yeah that's
a that's a really good question I don't
know I feel like I would return it
personally because when you keep it you
and you get something out of it whatever
it is if it's money I don't care what it
is you are losing something and if you
give it back to him
um you are kind of letting go of that
past that you had with him I feel like
that's really important for women to be
able to let go of something and to be
just to be you know
people need to be
able to let go of things and I think a
lot of the times we tend to hold on to
things that we think are still possible
but in turn it's it's ruining our
potential future relationships so like
you said Rich you know if you're holding
on to this ring and you find a potential
partner
what's going to happen if he finds out
you're still holding on to this
engagement ring obviously can hurt him
so you know letting go of that is super
important so I definitely just give it
back yeah it's a pretty significant
gesture to go out I mean you know to to
shop for one to buy it to compare it to
to you know the way that you propose and
give it to the woman you know typically
getting down on the 1D
yeah like it's a big uh you know it's a
big Fiasco so it'll sort of hold on to
that seems uh
seems like it would be detrimental to
Future to a future relationship or a
future potential relationship
um I think guys would inherently
maybe even be disgusted by the fact that
it still exists
I don't know does that give you some
food for thought without Alexandra
I just never
keep it
um
I have it with
being completely honest and transparent
with
um one of the dog that passed away his
ashes that I never opened
so it's a weird notion of not going back
into that past but not knowing what to
do with it
so I haven't
put it on since I took it off and
originally I left a note on the counter
with the ring there
and
then
decided to take it back so I think to
Sophie's point you know letting go of
the past you should have let it go
entirely and not tried to
make up and hold on to something that
you thought was still possible because I
left it when not when I fully found out
when I saw all of their texts is when I
left it and then
apologize for it back
no he didn't so he didn't bother asking
for it back okay go ahead I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out